[Musique]
début octobre pagode de vincennes une
partie de la communauté cambodgienne
s'est donné rendez vous pour célébrer la
fête traditionnelle des morts un
événement incontournable pour les khmers
l'ethnie dominante au cambodge
vannes est arrivé en france il ya près
de trente ans elle vient comme chaque
année honorer la tradition
[Musique]
celte en france et je viens faire les
autres aux narines au centre est thomas
couture
au rang des surprises
[Musique]
ce jour là il ya ma le roi des enfers
relâche les âmes des morts qui se mêlent
tous vivants l'occasion pour les
familles de rendre hommage à leurs
ancêtres à travers prières et offrandes
si ce jour est important pour la
communauté pour vannes à cette cérémonie
est lourde de sens en 1979 elle a dû
fuir son pays avec sa mère et ses frères
et soeurs
laissant derrière elle son père aux
mains des khmers rouges
il ya toujours pire
les petites et les grandes banques
turin jambe cassée en france
je
c'est le 22 juillet 1977 que disparaît
le père de vanna au cambodge depuis deux
ans polpot et les khmers rouges ont pris
le pouvoir et instaurer un régime de
terreur d'inspiration maoïste en quatre
ans ils vont éliminer plus d'un million
et demi de personnes soit un quart de la
population du pays un des plus sanglants
génocide du xxème siècle aujourd'hui 31
ans plus tard cinq responsables de ce
massacre sont enfin jugées par un
tribunal international parrainé par
l'onu jusqu'à ce jour le peuple
cambodgien n'a pas pu se livrer à un
travail de mémoire
vanna est arrivé sur le sol français en
1981 au cambodge une décennie
d'instabilité politique s'en suivit
repoussant sans cesse le retour au pays
ou encore rock ça reste toujours en pays
d'auray
et je peux retourner vers fois en 96 et
l'année dernière
c'est comme mon père étranger pour moi
ce que j'ai pu souhaiter en france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on compte près de cent cinquante mille
personnes d'origine cambodgienne sur le
territoire français alors avant scène la
fête des morts c'est aussi l'occasion de
partager un petit moment entre amis
fontenay-sous-bois nous sommes chez kim
la maman de vannes à l année
à côté de moi
c'est avec ses six enfants sous le bras
que kim a réussi à fuir le régime de pol
pot tilly à 30 ans makara et la petite
dernière à son arrivée en france à laver
cinq ans
ici le souvenir est omniprésent pourtant
dans leur fuite elles ont tout laissé
derrière elle
les seuls documents qu'ont et gardait la
du cambodge puisque on a on a fini par
tout perdre là quand même garder les
choses les plus importantes des extraits
d'acte de naissance de chaque image
d'elle même on a gardé ça pour pouvoir
entrer sur le territoire français on
savait que c'était très très important
donc heureusement elle a préféré même si
on était en train de traverser les
rizières ça nous montait jusqu'au
jusqu'à jusqu'au cou etc mais fallait
absolument les garder sur nous ses
papiers sa ans avec c'est hyper
important
donc nous a chassés de notre maison il
faut ça c est faux pour pas rester si
l'on il était dans le coma traille est
allé samoa samoa
au maire tremblay on n'y est pas
des souvenirs qui des années après reste
intacte mais le plus douloureux c'est
celui de la disparition du père
on est resté vingt ans sans pouvoir
faire le deuil de mon père et on avait
cet espoir qu'ils soient je n'ai pas
quelque part amnésique ou qui puisse pas
nous retrouver donc ont gardé cet espoir
et
puis moi ça me faisait mal donc j'ai
fait ça de recherche travers à travers
cette association justice pour le
cambodge est donc c'est là que j'ai
découvert
que mon père est mort
il a été
torturé pendant un mois et demi à la
prison de tuol sleng
toile ce lingot s-21 un centre de
détention où comme le père de makara
17000 personnes ont été torturés et
massacrés entre 1975 et 1979 une douleur
pour les familles que les procès en
cours au cambodge n'atténue pas vraiment
ceux qui gouvernent le cambodge je sais
quand même ce qu'ils ont fait partie des
khmers rouges donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai pas voulu mêler au procès j'avais
l'opportunité de porter plainte à partir
de là la france mais j'ai laissé tomber
parce que ben je sais pertinemment que
c'est une justice relative kim a passé
les trente dernières années de son
existence à se battre pour reconstruire
sa vie c'est en france à des milliers de
kilomètres de sa terre natale qu'elle
arrivera finalement à trouver un peu de
sérénité
ce soit comme chez moi
par contre mon père oui oui je le
pleurerai
s'est pas adapté mais maintenant je
l'adapté c'est comme témoin comme dans
mon pays
basilique de saint denis nous retrouvons
van hai sa maman une reproduction du
temple d'angkor vat le plus célèbre des
monuments du cambodge est exposée
pendant quatre jours c'est l'occasion
pour les deux femmes de s'imprégner d'un
peu de leur origine en moi je trouve
c'est magnifique
c'est un job et c'est bien fait ça
c'est le principe de cette assemblée aux
ancêtres qui ont construit ça
sur place vanard retrouve des amis
[Musique]
même si aujourd'hui la communauté
cambodgienne est parfaitement intégré
les saveurs du pays et l' envie d'y
retourner reste intacte ça permet le
fruit de pamiers de tenir entre deux
saisons avant de vous tenez aucun moi je
retiens tout ça qui nous renforcent la
tombe vide
ça va essayer d'y retourner là bas qu'on
peut voilà que salomé ce qui est risqué